like you know like I'm a Christian right
I don't like that are you Christian
yes do you go to do you watch the
gladiators and things like that
Christians no I just go to [__]
military funerals and go [__] [__]
no no no I have you haven't changed one
bit you should just know these he should
be internal in you the Bible is too
wordy all the story to where the Ten
Commandments are a load of [__] you
don't need all these things the Bible
should be one sheet of paper but on that
sheet of paper it should say try not to
be a [__] if you do that every day
you're being a good person I try to sell
these shaded Americans I don't like our
chances here's another one of these
civic customs swearing on the Bible
you understand that chin they tell you
to raise your right hand place your left
hand on the Bible does this stuff really
matter which hand does God really give a
[__] about details like this suppose you
put your right hand in the Bible you
raise your left hand with that count or
what God say sorry wrong hand try again
and what why does one hand have to be
raised what is the magic in this gesture
this seems like some sort of a primitive
voodoo mojo shtick why not put your left
hand on the Bible let your right hand
hang down by your side
it's more natural or put it in your
pocket remember what your mother used to
say don't put your hands in your pockets
does she know something we don't know is
this hand [__] really important well
let's get back to the Bible America's
favorite national theatrical prop
suppose the Bible they hand you to swear
on is upside down or backward or both
and you swear to tell the truth on an
upside-down backward Bible with that
count suppose the Bible hands you is an
old Bible and half the pages are missing
suppose all they have is a Chinese Bible
in an American Court or a Braille Bible
and you're not blind
suppose they hand you an upside down
backwards I knees Braille Bible with
half the pages missing
at what point does all of this stuff
just break down and become just a lot of
stupid [__] that somebody made up they
[__] made it up folks it's
make-believe it's make-believe now
let's leave the Bible aside we'll get
back to the science fiction reading
later the more important question is
what is the big deal about swearing to
God in the first place
why does swearing to God mean you're
gonna tell the truth wouldn't affect me
if they said to me you swear to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God
I'd say yeah I'll tell you about as much
truth as the people who wrote that
[__] Bible how do you like that
swearing on the Bible doesn't mean
anything it's kids spartan 'god is kid
stuff did you know that when you were a
kid if you if you told another kids
something he didn't quite believe he so
you swear to god i would always say yeah
i swear to god even if I was lying why
not what's gonna happen if I lie
nothing nothing happens if you lie
unless you get caught and that's a whole
different story sometimes a kid would
think he was being slick would be it
he'd say you swear on your mother's
grave I'd say yeah why not first of all
my mother was alive she didn't even have
a grave second of all even if she was
dead what's she gonna do rise from the
grave and come and haunt me come and
haunt me all because I told a lie to an
eight-year-old get [__] real with you
sometimes I would say I swear on my
mother's tits
kids are impressed with things like that
I mean I don't care about my mother's
tits either I don't care if they fell
off [__]
not my problem they're your chats Meyer
you keep an eye on it now you had to
live for a while you could didn't even
really have a place to live do you no no
no I I don't like to say not a place to
live you know you're right I didn't but
my mom my mom kind of my mom a lot
support system you know uh when I needed
an apartment and I went and got one on
my own I couldn't afford the rent
because I was trying to do comedy so my
mom she's very religious she said look
Kevin I'm gonna put you on my back I got
you for a year you can go out do what
you want to do I'm gonna support you
after that you don't find a way to feed
yourself then you got to go you got to
go back to school you got to do
something productive I said mom okay
give me a year during his comedy so my
mom's very overly just she was always
always telling me to pray read my Bible
I need rent money it's come time for
rent money I'm like mom you don't give
me rent this month she's like what did
you read your Bible
I'm like mom look I don't have time to
talk about the Bible stuff right now I
need the money like this thrill they're
gonna kick me out she's I read your
Bible didn't talk to me mom okay goodbye
hangover mom I don't go to this another
month go by I'm getting eviction notices
mom stop playing like if you don't give
me this money I'm gonna be homeless did
you read your Bible I don't right now
I'm not gonna have a place to read it in
a minute if you don't give me the money
she's like look I'm not gonna do this
with you Kevin read your Bible talk to
me it gets close to the third month I'm
like oh my god like they're really
threatened and kicked me out I finally
opened up my Bible when I opened it up
my mom put all of the checks for the
rest of the air in the Bible so I open
it and all of my rent checks fall out
and I just sat there with the dumbest
look on my face call my mom I said mom I
see what you did you put it in the Bible
she said did you read it no but I got
the child first David Brenner was the
biggest comic ever to come out of
Philadelphia
well again just passed away and we
should talk about him he's probably
watching from actually probably from
down below getting raped by the devil
well I mean that guy had some sins when
he died with whatever
I'm saying David Brenner metalife Sodom
and Gomorrha seem like bourbon if there
is a God then
that dude is an [__] which I know
somehow to popular belief but I do think
he's an [__] because every story
Abraham he went to Abraham in the middle
of the night there's only like eight
guys then and God would just once in a
while you just bother one of them so God
went to Abraham's house he's a man and
Abraham was like dude what what is up
what is up and God goes kill your son to
kill your son give me eyes ik I don't
know his name just kill him and Abraham
goes why cuz you don't love me if you
don't do it you know love me 2x so here
I was like dude you are insecure I don't
understand you but okay fine
goes wakes of it Isaac takes him to a
mountain somewhere I don't know I had to
be all drama queen about it and take a
little mountain couldn't just kill him
in his sleep then go back to sleep
but he took him to a woke the pork it up
dressed him took him to a mountain thank
Andy what are we doing oh just gonna
murder you it was like this God shows up
right before he does it goes hey what
are you doing this isn't in the Bible I
swear to God Isaac and Abraham because
I'm killing Isaac and guys like why
would you that's your kid what is wrong
with you and he's like oh uh and he just
went home feeling like a piece of [__]
that God is like a shitty girlfriend you
won't do it cuz you don't love me okay
I'll do it why are you doing it what the
you want from me I love my grandma loved
it very much my grandma taught me about
a lot taught me what religion is tell me
everything you can know about religion
one quick story tell you now when I
graduated from high school I graduated
high school my grandma came to me gave
me a big hug said Anthony I'm so proud
of you you're my first grandchild to get
to go to college what can I do for you
what can I give you before you go to
college I said honestly grandma all I
need from you is money yeah I know you
guys have never been but college is
expensive and my grandma said okay
Anthony I understand so a couple months
go by it's the end of the summer I'm
packing up my dad's car getting ready to
go to school and my grandma walks up
says Anthony here before you leave take
this and she handed me a brand new Bible
King James Version and I said thanks
grandma that's exactly what we talked
about
[Music]
he's got in the car and I went off to
school a couple of weeks go by I'm
hanging out my dorm room having a good
time on the phone rings it's my grandma
has a Anthony just calling to see how
college is going said grandma college is
the best I'm having the time of my life
but to be honest I'm already starting to
run low on money and I could use a
little bit like we talked about just hit
OK Anthony will let me ask you this have
you been reading your Bible and I said
totally grandma I'm on chapter 4
[Music]
she said okay Anthony well then I guess
I'll talk to you later
hung up the phone a couple of months go
by now I'm really starting to struggle
financially I'm have to drop out of
school if I don't get some money so I
called my grandma in a panic I say
grandma please it's Anthony I'm having
the time of my life in college I love it
here but if I want to graduate and I do
I need you to send me some money like we
talked about
you should why Anthony let me ask you
this have you been reading your Bible
and I said yes grandma I wish it was
longer
she said okay Anthony well then I guess
I'll talk to you later finally at the
end of the school year
I've got straight A's but I'm dropping
out of college because I have no more
money left and I'm furious I'm close to
tears cleaning out my dorm room when the
phone rings it's my grandma she's
Anthony hurt you're dropping out of
school today how come and I said you
know goddamn well how come grandma cuz
you wouldn't give me any money
she said well Anthony let me ask you
this did you read your Bible and I just
hung up the phone I was so pissed off
took everything out of that room last
thing I took off the shelf the last
thing I took out of that room was that
Bible my grandma given me took it off
the shelf held it in my hands and for
the first time I actually opened it up
and right there on the very first page
and my grandmother's handwriting it said
[__] you